now actually kind of admired the
restraint that they only made one ac/dc
joke actually with my luck it'll turn
out they made two or three and I only
caught one and I'll get that pointed out
in the comments as always hey everybody
so series 12 of Doctor Who continues
marches on as time is want to do which
brings us to Nikola Tesla's night of
terror
I was nervous about this one for a
couple of reasons the first is or $4.99
was I'm sorry orphan 55 was very not
good so after a strong start with spy
fall it it headed in a direction those
like oh oh dear and I have a pretty long
history of not liking most of the
historical set episodes of Doctor Who
especially the ones that involve
celebrity appearances and I don't mean
celebrity actors I mean celebrity
historical figures and then on top of
that I also caught from you know putting
together bits from the trailers that
this is also the one that was going to
have what looked like some variant of
the racnoss I'm also on the record as
having really not like the racnoss Queen
so this didn't look very promising to me
it's pretty good though it's not great
but I'll tell you for how many land
mines it could have stepped on at least
in terms of what I like or dislike about
this show historically it dodged them
pretty nimbly I think I've caught the
main thing with historical set episodes
that deal with famous historical figures
I think I finally figured out the
exception where that
works for me it's when the skillset of
the historical figure naturally lends
itself to being in being helpful or
getting involved with the sorts of
things the doctor is liable to deal with
so someone like Nikola Tesla or even
Thomas Edison with those kinds of
inventions and those kinds of minds that
makes sense
where it drives me crazy is when they
basically just get pulled into a plot
that they kind of have absolutely no
business being in like happens with your
Charles Dickens and your Queen
Victoria's and honestly I guess Winston
Churchill is a bit on the fence all
things considered given the way the
Daleks played into that but I hope
you're kind of getting what I'm what I'm
saying where the the nature and the true
history of that person doesn't actually
lend itself to this kind of story and
there's kind of pride in there and that
doesn't feel the case it feels like a
much more natural extension of a time
travel story and the kinds of things
that need to happen in a time travel
aliens story for Nikola Tesla or like I
said Thomas Edison cool and like
thematically can sometimes work I've
still got my issues with Rosa
but for theming what they went with it
made sense to go with her but like a lot
of the other ones this just well they're
just here because somebody thought it
would be cute and I just don't find it
cute you know Vincent worked because it
was an episode about depression haha and
yeah the guy was deeply deeply troubled
but anyways that's tangent over so this
episode specifically again strong
performances across the board I'm
starting to feel a little bit distanced
from this doctor again which is a little
bit odd and a little bit irritating
because I felt like I was being kept at
arm's length through most of series 11
and then by the end of that
kind of felt like I got it and what I
thought I had figured out carried me
through resolution carried me through
spy fall now I don't know again between
this and orphan 55 I'm starting to feel
like maybe I don't know this doctor I
thought I did I thought I had her
figured out I'm not so sure now and I'm
not gonna make the leap of saying that
that's down to inconsistent portrayal
because I don't think it is I just think
that the hook in that I thought I had
just isn't really the case not
consistently anyways because just the I
don't know she's she's become very harsh
and it's possible they might end up
balancing that where the impact of
realizing what the master did to
Gallifrey has put her in a harsh dark
place maybe that's how they'll
ultimately justify this it could work if
that's what they decide to do but for
right now it's putting me off of her a
little bit which is again kind of
frustrating for me but circling back to
the episodes I did the performance
overall was fine all the performances
were fine Nikola Tesla was good Thomas
Edison was good I actually quite
appreciated because as much as
historically speaking Thomas Edison was
a massive tool like just just the
horrible human being
I do like that it actually didn't go
super out of its way to denigrate him
and actually gave the guy some credit
for a few things like gave him credit
for the fact that he had a brilliant
mind and while it was a dickish way that
he went about it was also a brilliant
businessman which Tesla definitely
wasn't that was one area where
undoubtedly Edison outshined him and I
like that the episode doesn't
necessarily paint Edison as the bad guy
because of that
it does take Tesla side in the Tesla
versus Edison conflict but it that's
also one of those conflicts where the
more you learned about it the more
you're kind of just left to go yeah
that's I kind of got the side with the
with the guy with the stache but I I
liked that it felt balanced and not in a
both sides need to be presented as equal
no he's the bigger
he's the bigger dick in this in this
entire situation regardless of you know
how stubborn and pig in or whatever else
is wrong with Tesla personality-wise
Edison's the bigger dick in this
situation but that gets acknowledged
without painting him as a
one-dimensional character and also
without without going full o both sides
like no like they're humans they're
fallible he's not good he's not great
with people he's putting progress you
know secondary to can he make money off
it and if he can't he doesn't care so
you know it's it felt it felt well put
together well constructed either
nitpicky thing and like you could
probably justify this anyway but it is
stuck in my head for some reason it
really bothers me that the doctor called
aside Laurie and blast our alien because
I lorian's are from Earth I know there
are different species and I guess
depending on whether or not you choose
to define alien strictly as offworld or
if you're you're willing to go up just
other sentient species but they're
native to this planet in my mind that
doesn't make them aliens that annoyed me
and I'm really stuck in my head to some
odd editing jumps in this too like when
the doctor and Tesla and his assistant
whose name I am now forgetting which I
shouldn't because she was probably a
real person they've been really good
about filling out with with real
historical figures in these episodes so
apologies but you know they're like oh
I've got transferred
and they run out a door and then
suddenly they're on a train I'm like
yeah yeah glossed over a bit there that
that threw me off that was an odd
editing choice um so let's talk about
the skit I can't remember the names of
these things this gibbous covered skip
chip no what is it with you and creating
names for alien species that just slide
off my brain I can dregg's is it the
only thing I can remember and I don't
want to remember them all that much so
like what is it with him and like these
these names God so the Scorpion people I
actually kind of like that they're very
clearly an offshoot or like ag-related
lura sister species to the racnoss but
that never actually gets brought up and
it seems guy are they not gonna talk
about that but then I'm like it's so
frigging obvious to anyone who's seen
the runaway bride that this is a related
species that they kind of don't have to
say it and it becomes a little bit more
of an Easter I think like is it it's
very blunt
so Easter Egg might not be the right
term because that's usually for
something slightly more subtle know
what's going on here but you don't
actually have to say it so I kind of
like that they didn't also the
performance from the Queen of this
species boy hey less over-the-top and
campy than the racnoss Queen was thank
God I really couldn't stand that
performance in the runaway bride it was
just ah awful so bad and part of it I
felt bad for the actress because you
know she obviously in the run away where
I couldn't speak through through the
teeth yet I had her have if he had to
talk idea doctor ooh I'm glad that they
got that sorted and that wasn't so much
the case here so that helped I kind of
like the idea that they're that they're
scavengers who think they're superior
they have this sense of superiority
about themselves
that is basically their rationalization
for why they don't have to invent and
they don't have to build they're too
good for it why should they have to when
they can just take I should kind of like
that rationale and motivation because it
makes them have this massive superiority
complex with nothing backing it up
because they they don't do anything yet
they're also clearly high on the food
chain so like they can get away with
that self delusion at least for a while
until they run into the doctor so that
was that was cool
yes has another sort of she's just kind
of they're like her bits with like I'm
actually I'm feeling that way about most
of the companions so far none of them
have really had much of a highlight we
had I guess we had Ryan had a bit of a
highlight for orphan 55 but um Matt
they're just kind of along for the ride
and that's starting to bug me like I if
you're gonna tell me focus on the doctor
focus on like pains I will prefer or
focus on the doctor most of the time but
at the same time I'm like if you're
gonna have this many in here please do
something with them again much like in I
fall they're just kind of there they're
just tagging along not really helping
not really hindering they have like this
maybe there's a funny line here
maybe there's a nice interaction there
and maybe I'll go Oh God right that
person still in this story gah I forgot
so I'm I'm circling back on the fact
that the TARDIS is overcrowded again
because it probably wouldn't bother me
so much with they're just along for the
ride if there wasn't this many of them
because I think you can get away with
that every now and then when there's
only one other companion and you just
have a story where they just sort of run
along with the doctor and go like oh
okay and like smile and nod and do what
they're told but when there's three of
them doing that it really just
attention to the fact that they're not
contributing much because that's three
times as many people not contributing a
heck of a lot so that's it's not awful
in this episode but that's a point of
concern and again like I feel like I'm
making a lot of complaints but the thing
is they're not even the things I'm
complaining about aren't actually bad in
this episode they're just becoming
things that I'm realizing are bothering
me about this series if not the Chibnall
era overall so far and that is a little
bit frustrating to to do but like if I
were to take that out and just focus on
this this moves at a nice clip it's well
performed it's it's decently paced the
threat is credible the the way that it's
dealt with works and I bought it it it's
well done for the historical famous
person runs in the aliens thing it's not
bad it's it's pretty good it's on the
upper end of that kind of story and
that's coming from someone who doesn't
usually like those kinds of stories but
this episode is making me start to clock
things that I'm like I hope that's not
gonna be an issue for me for this whole
series
you know stuff that I'm gonna kind of
keep an eye on but but we'll see
so Nikola Tesla's night of terrors what
do you think of this one drop your
thoughts on the comments let's talk
about it if you want to help me pay my
rent and eat I have a patreon which
would be incredibly helpful at any
amount other than that you can also help
me out by hitting the like to subscribe
sharing this video around all that sort
of stuff but you also don't have to do
any of it because at the end of the day
you are the council and I'm just running
the meetings so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]